remember Kurt Russell's wild facial hair
from hateful eight
well he's cleaned it up a little for his
new movie Deepwater Horizon but the real
headline here is that this is also the
first film he has ever worked on with
his daughter cake I got to see mark and
my and my paw and Kurt together and I I
just thought I'm biased obviously it's
like that but I just thought wow what a
great combination they are the film is
based on the 2010 Deepwater Horizon
explosion in the Gulf of Mexico which
killed 11 people and resulted in the
worst oil spill in US history I play a
guy who worked on a rig who was an
ordinary guy who had to do extraordinary
things and I'd like to survive but to
help others on screen Kate is cast as
Mark's wife and while this is her first
time starring alongside her dad she says
a part of him is always with her when
she's on set growing up watching him
work he's such a pro and I think it's
been a great lesson for me when I was
younger I used to the kind of actress I
wanted to be I just loved everything
he's done joining Kate and Kurt are John
Malkovich and Jane the Virgin's Gina
Rodriguez hey thrusters are driving off
I'm not gonna be able to hold the rig in
place Gina and the rest of the cast
spent most of their time working on a
life-size oil rig created by director
Peter Berg for eight months crews built
the 75 foot tall set in the parking lot
of an abandoned amusement park in
Louisiana complete with a functioning
helipad and a gigantic tank holding more
than two million gallons of water the
sets were unbelievable I mean what man
can make is unreal and talk about
putting an actor right where they need
to be when you are just making this
life-sized oil rig on land it was
spectacular